je vais prendre la journée du 15
décembre mais donc j'étais en ville en
train de faire mes courses de noël pour
les petits parce qu'un accord en un
petit frère de 6 ans d'accord donc alors
aux environs de 10h30 je reçois un appel
de la cpe du collège durocher qui
m'appellent pour me faire comprendre que
l'ana chloé était tombé sur la cour de
l'école et qu'elle s'était cogné le
visage contre hand en enfer et qu'elle
avait une blessure importante sur le
visage qu'ils allaient appeler le 15 et
que si possible je peux me rendre à
l'hôpital où venir à l'école je l'aï pas
je suis en ville non loin du coup j'ai
pris le premier but je suis arrivé quand
je suis arrivé avait déjà l'hôtel et
look années ont autant pour moi des
ponts qui est j'ai rencontré le chef de
l' intervention qui à qui j'ai posé la
question je me suis présenté et j'ai
posé la question la gravité de la plaie
de la petite sur une échelle de 1 à 10
et les deux combien il m'a dit de 8 et
là j'ai pris peur j'ai pris peur et
j'avais le coeur qui bat très fort et
avant d'entrer dans la salle il m'a
demandé de me calmer parce que si elle
ne voit on pas nick lachey voilà parce
que elle elle était très calme d'accord
mais là et donc du coup quand je suis
entré dans la salle elle m'a tendu la
main en me disant
maman maman vient maman je suis désolé
je dis hou là moi j'avais pas vu la
profondeur de l'aplec je ne l'avais pas
vu du tout donc quand on l'a on l'a
amené aux urgences ou aux urgences de
chambéry donc avant en arrivant aux
urgences dont étant dans le camion des
pompiers jean enlever ses chaussures
parce qu'elle était couchée sur le
brancard il fallait enlever si ce sera
parce que ça la jeunesse tout et je les
ai rangé sous son lit sondhi où elle
était couchée donc on est arrivé on m'a
donné un sac où j'ai mis tous ses
affaires en sacs poubelles voilà qu'on
donne à tout le monde et donc on a un
grand ami qui trauma à l'hôpital de
chambéry donc conseillé la petite elle
était dans ses services dont j'ai
demandé à ses collègues de le contacter
delà de le faire venir parce qu'il
connaît très bien la petite et quand il
est arrivé la fiche la paix si tel avait
toujours le bandage donc on a chaud
voyez la plaie juste sous je voyais un
trait je n'avais pas la profondeur de la
plaie et donc quand il est arrivé il a
dit qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec la
petite et tous je dis pas voilà remet à
plat l'école qu'elle est tombée alors
elle est tombée alors qu'est ce qui
s'est passé là anna chloé toi
bras enfin pour commencer
mercredi 15 dans la cour je discutais
avec des camarades à propos d'un projet
qu'on devait faire
en chance et il ya un garçon qui a un il
ya quelqu'un qui est arrivé il m'a
frappé dans la cour comme ça ou c'est
qu'il ya quelqu'un tu connaissais dans
l'école oui il dans ma classe c'est dans
ta classe d'accord et tu avais eu déjà
eu des problèmes avec lui oui plusieurs
fois et donc il est arrivé sans rien
dire il était venu taper ou ici on m'a
frappé deux fois sur un look et sa
faillite avec moi il me donna un coup
comme ça d'accord et il est reparti non
et puis l'a dit un sale [ __ ] et il a
recommencé et symonds m'a énervé
je crois je lancerai geagea les le rôle
ce qui m'a fait venir me suis souvenu de
ce que maman elle m'a dit d'aller
prévenir à l'adulte avant de ressurgir
et
j'allais le faire donc je me faufile
entre des personnes et j'ai ressenti des
mâts nous pousser sur le dos et puis bah
moi j'ai connu un bond était dans les
escaliers non si tu es dehors dehors
donc tu es tombé et a été poussé dehors
oui parce que et donc quand on est quand
l'établissement dit qualité a été
poussée dans les escaliers donc c'est
c'est eh c'est pas du tout dans le passé
pourquoi ça s'est passé dans la cour
tous dans la cour donc tu as les verts
pour aller tu allais pour prévenir un
adulte et là il quelqu'un quitte à
pousser et est tombé sur la tête la
première sur le sol oui
sur un banc cancer sur un banc faire
d'accor est alors comment
l'établissement peut dire que c'était
dans un escalier alors que tu as été
retrouvés dans sur le banc mon avis
comment tu étais après après avoir été
poussé et était tombé tu étais conscient
tout est relevé tout de suite non pas
tout de suite mais il y avait une mare
de sang qui coulait mais j'ai pas le
temps de voir qui m'a qui m'a poussé
enfin il y avait trop de personnes qui
se moquaient de moi ou qu'ils allaient
appelez quelqu'un pour venir m'aider
enfin une seule personne
madeleine
l'établissement donc c'est qu'ils sont
des agresseurs ben non justement parce
que le lendemain de la chute de hannah
louis voilà parce que moi quand ils
m'appellent jusqu'à 18h45 pour moi c'est
qu'elle est tombée c'est un accident
donc quand elle se réveille s'il y avait
la nostalgie l'anesthésié qu'on lui a
faites on est rentré à la maison ce qui
avait une infirmière qui devait venir
lui faire des soins et après vers 21h30
comme ça je veux demande à la corée tu
peux me raconter ce qui s'est passé sur
ace combat dans la
voilà de manière rapide la cpe m'a dit
que voilà tu pourrais sur la cour et que
voilà tu avais assez des faillites et on
me dit non maman en fait on m'a poussé
j'étais avec des jld étaient en train de
discuter avec mes trois amis c'était la
fin du rassemblement et ya un camara qui
est venu matap au bras une fois eu deux
fois il m'a insulté c'est vrai que c'est
pas la première fois que tu subis des
injures racistes des agressions si c'est
l'indicible c'est ok le hockey
l'établissement qui trouve cet
établissement notre dame du rocher
collège c'est au collège notre dame du
rocher à chambéry chambéry d'accord
c'est ça et tu subi des agressions des
injures racistes depuis depuis longtemps
un oui j'en avais déjà par là ta maman
oui au tannat tu as parlé au proviseur
ou
non patronat
c'est incroyable ça quand même et donc
là où on a là l'établissement dit que
tout ça il faut puisqu'on a la même
l'avocat du proviseur qui s'est exprimé
sur bfm qui sera avec nous d'ailleurs
demain sur le plateau qui dit vraiment
quelle est elle et elle est tombée dans
les escaliers l'insee c'est la version
wii et mêmes la justice c'est ça qui est
frappant il ya l'établissement et même
le procureur a dit que vous vous étiez
seul il n'y a pas d'image de
vidéosurveillance pour pour corroborer
vos propos donc on a l'impression que
vous êtes totalement abandonnée par
l'établissement par la justice et vous
êtes seul avec votre version comment
vous expliquez que ce monde finalement
se retourne contre vous bah vous savez
moi quand j'ai inscrit ma fille en cet
été avec la la le règlement intérieur de
l'école que j'ai signé que le directeur
a signé c'est bien mentionné que l'école
et les placer sous la protection des
vies et aux surveillantes pour protéger
les biens et les personnes donc pour moi
quand ma petite me dis que maman on m'a
poussé je me dis qu'il faudrait
absolument que l'endroit où elle est en
biais des caméras et donc le lendemain
quand je suis parti la cpe m'a montré là
où la petite était tombé avec le mans il
était vraiment voilà un banc faire qu'un
réseau vallot good auquel elle se les
prix en plein dedans et je vois il ya
deux caméras une caméra qui donne sur la
cour et nous caméra qui donne sur le
lieu de l'accident jeudi à au moins on
verra et quand je demande au directeur
de l'école à avoir des caméras bas il me
faisait comprendre que les caméras au
bout de 24 heures l'espèce les fichiers
supprimés ya pas de sauvegarde et je dis
bah c'est une blague donc du coup c'est
des mecs passeur amener à l'école bas il
va battre des élèves et qu'on ne pourra
pas avoir accès
la petite disait qu'elle était avec deux
camarades est ce que justement ses
camarades dans une banale raconter leur
histoire
le savoir est ce que tes camarades à
elles ont pris position est ce qu'elle
dise la même version que soit la
mainmise noir non le sang rien du tout
donc du coup quand on est parti à
l'audition commissariat donc on lui a
donné les noms des élèves qu'elle ne
connaissait pas donc on n'a pas appelé
ses camarades qui étaient sur la cour
pour témoigner voilà qui n'ont pas eu
l'occasion de donner donc là on va on va
passer pour le moment il fallait que je
reprenne des forces parce que ma vie est
là basculer ma vie de moments il a
basculé des puits alors c'est vous qui
avez voulu médiatiser cette affaire en
posant très longs messages sur les
réseaux sociaux
avec le visage d'un matelot et
qui nous a tous choqués voulait faire
réagir sur cette affaire et vous c'est à
dire que vous êtes sûr de la version
d'anne à chloé exactement je connais
parfaitement ma fille et puis je ne
m'attendais pas à cette montée mais
médiatique sur les réseaux sociaux si
vous voulez ma mémé publication c'est
sur ma page quantité d'événements où
j'avais 1062 que les photos sons sont
très choquantes donc forcément ça fait
rage en énormément les gens ils ont
partagé il va bien sûr et puis si celle
ci c'est une agression raciste forcément
ça peut pas rester impuni et c'est vrai
que j -louis ce qui est très étonnant
c'est que à notre connaissance mais
peut-être que vous à les infirmer votre
fille n'a pas été auditionné par la
justice
elle n'a pas été entendue pour livrer
son témoignage
ce qui paraît fou est ce que c'est vrai
ma fille lorsque le dimanche le dimanche
après l accident était mercredi et le
dimanche après son accident le procureur
de chambéry s'est prononcé ma fille
n'avait pas encore été entendu elle est
entendue le mercredi d'après d'accord
alors il ya aussi je vous dis des
réactions sont parfois les traîner
jusque l'adresse personnelle du
directeur du collège a été diffusé il a
été placé sous protection policière
après des menaces de mort ça vous le
regrettez forcément madeleine c'est vrai
que ça c'est c'est compliqué de voir ses
rimes je suis tellement désolée mais je
crois qu'en france c'est pas comme au
cameroun dont je viens la grèce
personnel de quelqu'un je crois que
c'est un mot fin c'est des chiffres
ténor s'est déplacée des rues cdd chemin
c'est déplace donc dire l'adresse
personnelle le directeur de l'école
quand moi je publie on me fait
comprendre qu'on est allé sur google on
a vu qu'il adjoint au maire à la ravoire
mais la ravoire c'est une communauté moi
j'ai travaillé super millar à voir c'est
non loin de chambéry j'ai dit non mais
en fait c'est si un élu donc quand tu es
élu comté directeur dans l'établissement
où il ya plein d'enfants qui viennent
qui est public je crois que dire que il
est adjoint au maire je ne crois pas que
c'est la grèce au pire sauf si je
comprends pas bien le français le faire
de dis que tu es le président la
république s'est pas donné ton est alors
que moi j'ai jamais donné son adresse
avait choisi de porter plainte
aujourd'hui donc j'ai porté plainte
depuis le jour où il m'a dit que ses
caméras en fait ça quand ça marchait pas
que la halle enquête est en cours
l'enquêté est en cours et la petite est
entendue et d'éplucher pas de nouvelles
et je me pose des questions
d'accord alors
un à chloé toit sert étudie l'histoire
elle va très très loin c'est un crois
parce que tout le monde en parle c'est
très médiatisé ce que ça te fait peur
tout ça ou est ce que toi tu envie que
la vérité éclate et que tant honnie
vraiment voilà que les gens sachent
vraiment ce que tu as vécu et ta version
ouais enfin je veux que tous et
madeleine alors bas pour moi je veux
déjà lire les quelques mots si vous me
permettez cyril le petit temps qu'il
reste assez les mots kanak l'ol écrit et
moi j'ai d'accord le salon se destine à
qui s'est dessinée à tout le monde à
tous ceux qui nous regardent l'aide de
nos clowns anatomy exact allez-y alors
je m'appelle alain clôt et je suis une
petite fille qui aime la danse le
maquillage et le mannequinat j'aime
aussi j'aime aussi beaucoup les selphy
et les vidéos avant je me sentais bien
dans ma peau je me trouvais jolie car ma
maman m'a toujours appris à avoir
confiance en moi depuis que je suis
arrivé dans cette école j'ai peu à peu à
peu à peu perdu confiance en moi des
élèves se moque d'eux souvent de moi il
se moque de mon poids de ma couleur de
peau maintenant à cause de ce qui s'est
passé je me sens mal dans ma peau quand
je sors je me sent pointer du doigt je
me sens différente à cause de cette
cicatrice j'ai l'impression d'avoir une
étiquette sur le visage ils ont juste
enfin réussi à me sentir différentes
j'avais pour projet de devenir
biologiste
mais avec ce que j'ai vécu j'aimerais
devenir avocate ou juge pour aider et
défendre les enfants qui subissent ou
ont subi les agressions ou des
harcèlements quand moi je voudrais
demander à toutes les personnes qui nous
regardent d'arrêter de diffuser le
racisme et l'harcèlement cela des crues
la vie des gens on est tous humains
après moi aimer nos différences je veux
à travers mon histoire je veux qu'à
travers mon histoire les gens réagissent
et que les parents montrent à leurs
enfants que c'est la différence qui fait
ou qui fait tourner le monde je veux
qu'on me fasse justice je veux de
nouveau me sentir en sécurité à l'école
je veux que les les élèves me respectent
et m'apprécient tel que je suis je veux
plus avoir peur je suis un à chloé et je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]